hey Vsauce Michael here the loudest clap
ever recorded clocked in at 130 decibels
and the world record for fastest
clapping was recently set at 802 claps
per minute
clapping is the most common human body
noise others are meant to hear that
doesn't involve the vocal cords it's a
great built-in percussion instrument but
clapping has also become a collective
social gesture that we use in groups to
express admiration approval especially
for things that happen on stage so here
I am on stage but to show approval to
show that they like things why do humans
amazing question
when applauding a person creates claps
at a rate of about two and a half to
five claps per second kinetic energy
from the hands is converted into
acoustic energy mainly within the 2200
to 2800 Hertz range the frequencies clap
on clap off devices detect but many
other frequencies are created during a
single clap and different hand positions
create different spectra of frequencies
most of which are not whole number
multiples of each other which is why a
clap can't make a musical note a
discernible definite pitch the way a
clarinet or piano or the human voice can
if vocalizations can be so finely
controlled why clap I mean it's such a
crude messy noise well at a fundamental
and physiological level the impulse to
clap may have originated as a reaction
to an overflowing of enthusiasm and
immediate and primitive reaction to
excitement Stephen Connor colorfully
puts it this way if the distinctive
sound of the human is the sound of
language then sound produced from other
places than the mouth always has the
taint of the gratuitous the excessive or
the prescribed clapping is the benign
Superflex of the body the diarrhea of
sound he calls it a spilling over of
feeling a burst of energy unfiltered by
language or thought it's a way to burn
off extra enthusiasm but if clapping is
so natural and involuntary to the
individual how did it become coded into
Western etiquette and expected behavior
you sometimes feel pressure to do even
if you don't want to Desmond Morris
called modern clapping patting a
performer on the back from a distance
and other theories have called clapping
high-fiving yourself for something
someone else has
but in its current form there is another
thing besides yourself and the
performance that might be truly driving
applause a superorganism called the
crowd a study published in the Journal
of the Royal Society found that an
individual's contribution to applause
seems to have less to do with their
actual opinion as to the quality of the
performance and has more to do with the
behavior of the collective group the
anonymous group voice aspect of applause
also makes sense when you consider the
fact that clapping is a great equalizer
studies have shown that as opposed to
vocalizations which can betray a lot
about the people who make them subjects
cannot guess better than chance whether
the clap they hear is from a man or a
woman nor can they guess the size of the
individual based solely on the sound of
their clap clapping may have become the
standard nonverbal gesture of admiration
because it is arguably the loudest the
easiest and the most democratic
performers can't hear a thumbs-up or a
wink
not everyone can snap their fingers and
clapping is less disruptive than
stomping feet or waving around big
objects
moreover historically authorities have
encouraged clapping in the sixth century
BC Cleisthenes came to power in ancient
Greece as a democratic reformer and made
behaviors like clapping a civic duty the
proper way for the masses to express
admiration for their leader there wasn't
enough time for everyone to meet and
greet his or her leader but they could
all greet their leader together as one
super organism with one voice
applause by the early 19th century the
desire to code appropriate group
reactions and encourage them by example
was quite official agencies offered
clacks for hire professional applaud
whoo with memorize operas attend them
like normal opera goers and clap cry or
laugh at appropriate times so that the
actual audience would know when to
properly do what it's interesting that
five or six months after being born
human babies begin to realize that their
hands can work together clapping is a
natural reaction to this realization but
parenting books have to advise parents
to teach their children to connect
clapping with group happiness and
celebration the connection itself not
being inevitable to this day applause
signs reinforce audience behavior simply
because those with authority are
requesting it not because it is a
natural reaction but because it can be
and historically has been socially
imposed so what's the future of applause
well last week I hung out with the guys
from grand illusions really fascinating
channel and they pointed out something
strange how many times have you listened
to your favorite song probably quite a
few right you've listened to songs you
don't like plenty of times but as
recently as a hundred and fifty years
ago people only heard their favorite
symphony maybe two or three times in
their entire life if you wanted music
you had to go to a concert or pick up an
instrument or sing there was no other
way but now because of recorded music
mp3 players and phones and tablets and
personal computers and digital libraries
allow us to be an audience of one an
audience all by ourselves not just when
professionals get together and draw a
crowd in the 1990s faith popcorn gave
this broader phenomenon a name cocooning
the internet home entertainment cell
phones alarm systems self-checkout
filters for our personal air and water
are all paraphernalia of kakuni a
tendency toward more lonely solitary
experiences in the last 30 years in my
episode about the friendzone I talked
about how kakuni might be making
friendship meeting new people and new
unexpected ideas a waning experience but
applause is safe right I mean applause
isn't about meeting new people it's
about becoming them becoming a
superorganism that speaks with one
unindicted roar and concerts and live
performances are still big parts of our
lives but what's fascinating is that
more entertainment is more available
than ever before and despite being TV
shows movies games and music this new
entertainment is increasingly consumed
like books in solitude alone you don't
need to applaud alone in a cocoon but to
be sure alone on the internet we don't
applaud but we do like and share and
favorite and retweet those actions might
be a sort of our sex applause in real
life your clap is lost in the crowd
aggregating into the total sound and
online so are your likes and favorites
they join a collective gesture as a sort
of digital applause a pessimist might
feel like these new collective gestures
are hollow lonely a sad replacement for
actual social experiences but what's
really happening because a like is not
necessarily lonely a retweet by its very
nature isn't a clap lost in the crowd
it's a clap that joins the crowd but is
also trace of
directly back to you maybe cocooning
maybe the rise of applause substitutes
like digital applause is something to be
worried about or maybe it's the natural
result of having so many applause worthy
things just a few clicks away
we can't applaud all of them so we have
evolved more scalable reactions which
incidentally are more personal
instead of being pathetic clicks from an
increasingly isolated cocooned
population digital applause might be
like something else that comes from
cocoons and having more of them
something beautiful butterflies and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]